Doni EPS musei rayon Ricci spanning
decades continents and cultures these
unforgettable characters represent
vastly different facets of the human
experience but have one thing in common
the extraordinary talent of the actors
who brought them to life here are the
nominees for actor in a supporting role
bark adoptee captain Phillips Bradley
Cooper
American hustle Michael Fassbender 12
years of slave Jonah Hill the wolf of
Wall Street Jared Leto Dallas buyers
club and the Oscar goes to Jared Leto
incredible Ellen I love you to my fellow
nominees I'm so proud to share this
journey with you I'm in awe and have so
much respect for you all to the Academy
thank you
in 1971 Bossier City Louisiana there was
a teenage girl who was pregnant with her
second child she was a high school
dropout and a single mom but somehow she
managed to make a better life for
herself and her children she encouraged
her kids to be creative to work hard and
to do something special
that girl is my mother and she's here
tonight and I just want to say
I love you mom thank you for teaching me
to dream to my brother Shannon the best
big brother in the world you're a true
artist thank you so much for sharing
this insane an amazing adventure that is
thirty Seconds to Mars and for being my
best friend I love you thank you to all
the dreamers out there around the world
watching this tonight and places like
the Ukraine and Venezuela I want to say
we are here and as you struggle to to
make your dreams happen to live the
impossible we're thinking of you tonight
and this is incredibly special as well
because there's so many people that
helped me get here and I just want to
say thank you to Focus Features to mix
olive in' to Jim talk to Jason Weinberg
to emma Ludwick to Callie
Adams to the entire Dallas buyers club
team Matthew I love you Jean Marc and
this is for the 36 million people who
have lost the battle to AIDS and to
those of you out there who have ever
felt and justice because of who you are
or who you love tonight I stand here in
front of the world with you and for you
thank you so much and good night